et si on pouvait miner les océans pour
sauver la planète et se faire plein de
brouzoufles au passage complet non c'est
pas ça vous avez peut-être entendu
parler du Dipsy mining en bon français
l'exploitation minière des fonds marins
l'ultime frontière alors c'est pas
encore le cas il y a pas d'exploitation
en cours mais ça risque de se
concrétiser dans les mois ou les années
à venir donc bah c'est peut-être le bon
moment ce documenter là-dessus alors
j'ai mis qu'est-ce que c'est exactement
que ce Dipsy mining est-ce une
opportunité incroyable ou le prochain
scandale écologique alors d'abord
pourquoi pourquoi je vis pourquoi je
meurs et surtout pourquoi les Six pieds
sous mer pour extraire des minerais bah
parce qu'il y en a pas mal justement
regardez ça ça c'est un pré-salé
littéralement ou les moutons sont des
nodules polymétalliques à nous
c'est des boules de pétanque riches en
hydroxyde de manganèse et de fer qui
contiennent aussi du cuivre du cobalt et
du nickel et des traces de lithium de
molibènes et quelques terres rares un
bon petit cocktail ces ingrédients
justement on en a besoin dans la vie de
tous les jours on s'en sert pour les
téléphones les transports les
ordinateurs les batteries électricité
les miroirs les bijoux les peintures les
produits pharmaceutiques les moteurs la
construction l'automobile les plastiques
les céramiques il s'avère qu'avec
l'avènement des véhicules électriques et
le développement des pays en
développement la demande en ces métaux
augmente drastiquement ces métaux
aujourd'hui on les prélève sur la terre
ferme pas le choix mais ça pose pas mal
de problèmes sans même parler du fait
que certaines ressources soient
concentrées dans des territoires pas au
sommet de la régulation environnementale
sont pas trop un exemple de respect de
l'environnement et des humains entre la
dégradation des habitats la pollution de
l'air des rivières et des nappes
phréatiques les déchets toxiques
l'expropriation des populations locales
bref si on pouvait trouver une
alternative ce serait bon art et c'est
là qu'interviennent les grands fonds
marins situés au-delà de 200 mètres de
profondeur la particularité de ces
nodules c'est qu'ils sont bien plus
concentrées en métaux que les cailloux
qu'on extrait sur le continent une
entreprise de minage en eau profonde
avance que la moitié des moutons de
cette zone là permettrait de construire
un milliard de voitures électriques en
émettant un tiers de moins de gaz à
effet de serre que les le minage
terrestre ça se réfléchit et c'est pas
le seul avantage du dipsyminding déjà
les grands fonds représentent 60% de la
surface de la Terre avec plein minerais
potentiels dessus en plus 80% de ces
nodules sont situés dans les eaux
internationales donc ils appartiennent
pas à un pays donné à priori voilà qui
reballe les cartes de la géopolitique il
y a 15 baissée pour la ramasser en plus
ces moutons donc bah c'est tout bénef
non mais moi en lisant tout ça je me
suis dit ouais quand même hein
mais avant de nous emballer regardons de
plus près d'où viennent ces minerais et
comment on les extrait
à commencer par nos moutons ces moutons
se forment dans les plaines abyssales
par précipitation de métaux contenus
dans l'eau de mer autour d'un petit
noyau ça peut être un bout de coquillage
une dent de requin une arête un os de
Dodo que Noé a mangé pendant la
traversée faut dire qu'il devait trouver
le temps long et puis c'est tentant
aussi quand on vit littéralement dans un
énorme garde-manger et donc par contre
je concentrique les nodules grandissent
au fil du temps un gentiment posé sur le
fond marin faut pas être pressé par
contre on est sur quelques millimètres
de croissance par million d'années on
estime que nos champs de moutons
s'étendraient sur l'équivalent de la
superficie de l'Asie certaines zones
sont très riches en moutons comme
celle-ci au milieu du Pacifique qu'il
focalise l'attention des États et des
industriels on l'appelle la sixizn ou
zone de fracture de Clarion la quantité
de manganèse nickel et cobalt rien que
là dépasserait la totalité des réserves
la totalité des réserves continentales
connues oui c'est à ce point-là
maintenant la question c'est comment
qu'on peut extraire ces moutons qui sont
parfois à plusieurs milliers de mètres
de profondeur et bien déjà il me semble
que c'est plus ou moins en réflexion
mais ce sera dans tous les cas un sacré
défi technologique il va falloir que les
engins supportent des énormes
différences de pression température
densité salinité et pH ce sera pas du
gâteau tout ça se fera sans doute avec
des machines contrôla à distance on va
pas descendre des mineurs mineurs à 6000
mètres de profondeur quand même les
industriels sont pleins d'humanité
l'idée pour ramasser ces machins là
c'est d'avoir trois éléments
un aspirateur qui se balade sur le
plancher océanique pour se fluorper les
premiers centimètres de sédiments où se
trouvent les nodules un ascenseur pour
ramener tout ça en surface et un bateau
qui trira les nodules du reste du
sédiment lequel sera rejeté en mer dans
un contexte commercial il faudrait
ramasser plusieurs milliers de tonnes de
nodules par jour pour être rentable
c'est énorme et potentiellement les
impacts environnementaux aussi d'abord
comment vont réagir les bestioles
abyssales quand on va leur sucer
l'habitat dans un Roomba géant et bien
il y a fort à parier que c'est la fin
mon ami mais c'est pas tout parce que
outre la dégradation de l'habitat et la
pollution sonore et lumineuse du
chantier ça va aussi remuer du sédiment
et notamment quand les machines vont
rejeter après traitement l'eau et les
déchets dans l'océan plus ou moins près
du fond et ça c'est catastrophique pour
plusieurs raisons ça va créer un panache
de sédiments comme une tempête de sable
qui peut retomber en plus sur les
organismes du sol qui a été tenu bon
jusque là vous avez survécu à
l'aspirateur et c'est Pompéi maintenant
mais c'est jamais qu'une partie des
particules qui vont retomber les autres
vont rester en suspension dans la
colonne d'eau
pendant des années sur des dizaines des
centaines voire des milliers de
kilomètres du coup l'eau va se troubler
et on fait un bon gros fuck aux
organismes filtrer comme les éponges qui
ont besoin d'un milieu transparent pour
vivre tant pis aussi pour les organismes
qui communiquent et chassent à vue comme
les espèces bioluminescentes
à la vache pourquoi j'ai fait ça ne
faites jamais ça c'était complètement
débile mais c'est pas fini ce panaché ce
panache ne contient pas que des
sédiments il peut aussi porter des
métaux cela même qu'on a remué pour les
récupérer souvenez vous savez le cuivre
le cadmium le zinc le plomb et ben ils
sont toxiques pour la vie marine et eux
ils pourraient rester en suspension dans
la colonne d'eau pendant des siècles
non des siècles pendant lesquels ils
vont pouvoir contaminer voir décimer les
organismes vivants et remonter gentiment
la chaîne alimentaire jusqu'à par
exemple le poisson dans nos assiettes
miam miam et à la température aussi ce
que cette eau qui ressort après
traitement va être réchauffé c'est pas
voulu c'est juste les machines qui
émettent de la chaleur en triant le bon
minéral de livret a tel point que cette
eau pourrait être 10 degrés plus chaud
dans sortant qu'en entrant vous imaginez
un peu l'impact que ce petit sauna peut
avoir sur les organismes du fond qui
sont au contraire habitués à des
conditions extrêmement stables en plus
que c'est pas trois palourdes qui vont
être chatouillés par la spirogé je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez la zone cCZ
dont on parlait au début et ben des
scientifiques ont étudié et 70 à 90% des
espèces trouvées là-bas étaient
inconnues jusqu'à lors
ils ont trouvé des poules pour des
poissons des coraux des crinoïs des
organismes unicellulaires de parfois 5
cm de long donc ces zones qu'on aimerait
bien raser non seulement elles sont
habitées mais en plus elles pourraient
abriter une faune à la fois abondante et
diversifiée un peu comme nos aisselles
en fait les chercheurs se sont même
rendu compte que plus il y avait de
nodules plus il y avait de vie avec
certaines espèces de cor vous retrouvez
que sur les nodules
donc si on enlève les nodules mais ces
écosystèmes sont encore très mal connus
la rumeur dit qu'on connaît mieux la
surface de la Lune que le fond de nos
océans donc difficile de prévoir les
impacts possibles du minage si on sait
même pas à quoi ça ressemble ni qui
réside et comment ça fonctionne en fait
la question la plus importante c'est
est-ce que ces endroits peuvent se
remettre vite si on exploite ses champs
de nodules en d'autres termes qu'elle
est la résilience de ces écosystèmes
mais ça tombe bien que vous posez la
question parce que il y a un début de
réponse grâce à des expérimentations qui
datent d'y respectivement 20 et 37 ans
les chercheurs ont simulé le passage
d'un engin de ramassage des nodules et
ils ont regardé comment ces zones se
remettaient après ça c'est la zone
témoin ou l'aspirateur n'est pas passée
et ça c'est 37 ans après qu'il est passé
dans la zone Dyson il y a moins de
modules c'est normal ils ont pas
repoussé en 40 ans mais surtout il y a
beaucoup moins de bestioles qui vivent
et elles y sont moins diversifiées les
scientifiques se sont particulièrement
intéressés à la faune qu'on retrouve sur
le fond qu'on appelle l'épifone et leur
constat c'est qu'il y a 70% de bestioles
en moins qui nage près du fond et 8 fois
moins d'organismes accrochés par terre
donc oui il y a une sorte de
recolonisation dans ces zones mais
c'était mieux avant d'après les
chercheurs les écosystèmes des plaines
abyssales pourraient mettre des dizaines
sinon des centaines d'années à se
remettre du passage des aspirateurs pas
cool du tout
[Musique]
effectivement extraire ces nodules
polymétalliques ça viendra avec un sacré
prix pour les abysses heureusement pour
nous les plaines ne sont pas les seuls
endroits on retrouve des miches des
miches les plaines ne sont pas les seuls
endroits où on retrouve des richesses
minérales dans les grands fonds suivez
moi on va aller dans une source
hydrothermale
rien à voir avec Évian ni Vichy bien que
ce soit mon régime préféré on les
appelle aussi fumeurs blancs et fumeurs
noirs
imaginez des geysers mais au fond de
l'eau il se forme quand il y a des
volcans sous-marins par exemple au
niveau des dorsales dans ces zones là
comme ça bouge beaucoup le fond marin et
scarifié de failles comme les poignées
de votre petite sœur Emo et ce qui se
passe c'est que l'eau de mer va
s'engouffrer dans toutes ses fissures et
elle va se rapprocher du magma
sous-jacent
ou c'est moi et au passage elle va
devenir assis de sa mère arracher des
minéraux à la roche adjacent c'est ces
minéraux métalliques qui nous
intéressent et puis cheat l'eau ressort
en geyser et c'est précieux métaux
dissous vont précipiter pour former les
cheminées des fumeurs ou bien ils vont
retomber en pluie tout autour et
s'incruster dans ce qu'on appelle les
bouts c'est des dépôts donc qui vont
être riches en cuivre zinc plomb arsenic
cobalt et même or et argent et c'est ces
trucs là que les industriels veulent
miner petit coquin
aujourd'hui on peut trouver plusieurs
dizaines de mètres de couches de dépôts
comme ça qui s'étendent sur de toutes
petites zones c'est ultra localisé la
plus grande source hydrothermale connue
et 14 fois plus petite que le Vatican et
le pire c'est que j'ai trouvé cette info
tel quel dans une étude j'ai rien eu à
faire des petites zones mais nombreuses
puisqu'on en compte pas moins de 300 et
certaines d'intérêts économiques l'une
d'elles contiendrait 15 millions de
tonnes de minerais elle est située du
côté de Larry d'océanique Juan des
foucas en français Jean de Fuck alors
comment on extrait ces bidules
et bien ce sera facile de répondre parce
que ça a déjà été fait par les Japonais
en 2017 ils sont descendus à moins 1600
mètres au large d'Okinawa et ils ont
prélevé une poignée de ses sulfures
polymétaliques juste pour goûter comme
ça schizophré c'est un dispositif assez
similaire à l'extraction des nodules
sauf qu'ils ont utilisé plusieurs
machines sur le fond marin pour détacher
les dépôts métalliques là et puis les
ont acheminé en surface grâce à une
pompe et stockée sur un bateau et encore
une fois tout ce qui n'est pas
intéressant et rejeté en mer à nage
Turbide et mokuntasakabat donc
globalement les mêmes impacts que pour
les chambres nodules qu'on a vu le hic
c'est que ces sources hydrothermales
sont des oasis de vie oui je parle bien
des geysers de flux d'acide porté à 400
degrés et bourré de sulfure et de métaux
vraiment la faune qui s'est développée
là-bas c'est Chuck Norris avec des
nageoires
[Musique]
on se demande même si la vie sur Terre
ne serait pas apparue dans ce genre
d'écosystème là donc ils sont
extrêmement importants du point de vue
scientifique les chercheurs ont déjà
découvert plus de 500 nouvelles espèces
autour de ces sources hydrothermales du
poisson de la crevette de l'escargot des
vers des bactéries comme un plateau de
fruits de mer à Noël en plus il y a
pratiquement pas deux communautés de
fumeurs qui sont pareils d'un côté de
l'océan c'est des collégiens en manque
de popularité de l'autre des
intermittents du spectacle en sarouel il
y a de tout certains scientifiques
avancent même que 85% des espèces des
fumeurs pourraient être endémiques donc
on les retrouverait qu'à un seul endroit
sur terre mais c'est pas parce que ces
espèces se sont adaptées à des
conditions de vie ultra hardcore
qu'elles survivent dans le noir complet
dans une aussi chaude qu'elle ferait
bouillir d'envie des panzanie et qui ont
carrément inventé un autre type de
métabolisme basé non pas sur la
photosynthèse mais sur la chimiosynthèse
qu'elles peuvent pour autant survivre à
une grosse perturbation changer leur
morning routine privilège de leur
souffre du matin et ils seront peut-être
en PLS surtout si vous détruisez leur
maison et la broyez en petits morceaux
sous leurs yeux les bons points parce
qu'il y en a c'est que ces fumeurs
mettrai plusieurs milliers d'années à se
former et non pas million donc c'est
déjà mieux que de s'attaquer aux nodules
d'autant plus que les zones couvertes
sont très réduites donc potentiellement
les impacts de l'extraction pourraient
l'être aussi et côté pollution
métallique a priori cette faune là est
tranquille puisqu'elle vit déjà dans un
bouillon de métaux toxiques et elle s'y
adaptée donc un peu plus un peu moins
pour tous les autres impacts c'est
difficile de prévoir comment un
écosystème pareil réagirait d'autant
plus qu'il y en a pas de identique bon
donc on a nos nodules polymétalliques au
fond des planables nos dépôts sulfureux
des sourcils de rethermales et on a une
troisième et ultime source de minerai
dans nos abysses une qui va plaire à mon
public l'épreuve que j'embrasse ce sont
les croûtes polymétalliques oui
polymétalique encore l'océan est plus
métal que le Hellfest alors donc nous
sommes cette fois sur les monts
sous-marins et ces croûtes dont je vous
parle ça se forme comme un glaçage de
Ferro manganèse par précipitation des
métaux contenus dans l'eau sur le socle
rocheux a même notre flan de montagne un
glaçage qui peut atteindre 25 cm
d'épaisseur quand même il faut avoir de
bonnes dents c'est ignoble ils
contiennent à peu près la même chose que
nos nodules polymétalliques du début
donc beaucoup de cobalt du manganèse
nickel cuivre et même du zirconium et
elle se forme tout aussi lentement de
l'ordre du millimètre par millions
d'années c'est dans le Pacifique qu'on
en trouve le plus notamment dans le
Pacifique Nord puisque c'est là que la
croûte océanique
et la plus vieille environ 160 millions
d'années et donc c'est là que les
croûtes polymétalliques ont eu le plus
le temps de se former et de grandir sur
la croûte océanique ça fait un sandwich
de croûte cette histoire un sandwich de
croûte fort intéressantes même parce que
on a estimé qu'elles abritaient par
endroits 4 fois plus de cobalt 3,5 fois
plus dix trium et 9 fois plus de tellure
que l'entièreté des réserves
continentales connues
bon appétit pour prélever ces minerais
on sait pas très bien ce que les
industriels ont prévu de faire vu que
les infos sont pas public mais dans tous
les cas ça va pas être facile de
décoller les croûtes de la roche vu
qu'elles sont vraiment cimentées dessus
on sait pas s'ils vont y aller au burin
ou s'il préféreront leur faire écouter
du Orelsan en boucle jusqu'à ce qu'elle
décide d'elle-même de s'en aller mais
dans tous les cas il y a fort à parier
que si des bestioles habitent sur ses
croûtes et ben elles vont pas faire long
feu bon mais si c'est difficile à choper
on peut au moins espérer que ces
croutelles soient déserte non et bien
que nenni Léman sous-marins sont
carrément des hotspots de biodiversité
et oui pas de bol
[Musique]
ils sont couverts de récits de coraux
d'anémone et d'éponge qui abrite près de
800 espèces de poissons avec aussi des
requins des tons des tortues des cétacés
des crustacés des mollusques et des
oursins étoiles de mer c'est
écosystèmes-là sont les plus mal connues
des trois dont on a parlé mais certains
chercheurs avancent que 80% de ces
espèces pourraient être endémiques le
célèbre ours polaire des abysses c'est
de plus en plus ignoble j'adore écouter
résilience me direz-vous et bah c'est
mal barré faudra attendre plusieurs
millions d'années pour que nos croûte
repoussent et côté biodiversité comme
finalement l'extraction minière
ressemble un peu au chalutage profond
des chercheurs se basent sur des
expériences de chalutage dans les monts
sous-marins pour imaginer les impacts
potentiels de l'exploitation minière et
il s'avère que les traces du passage
d'un chalut se voient encore 10 à 30 ans
plus tard donc on peut s'attendre à la
même chose avec une opération de minage
en plus la faune il sera probablement
complètement différente après parce que
les communautés qui peuplent les Mons
sous-marins sont des espèces qui vivent
longtemps et qui grandissent très
lentement par exemple certains coraux ou
éponges sont séculaires voire
millénaires donc quand l'espace est
brutalement rasé
déjà ces espaces crèvent et ensuite il
est très vite recolonisé par d'autres
espèces plus réactives et tant pis pour
les PP et les mémés ils avaient qu'à
être plus rapide
il faut bien garder en tête que là je
parle d'impact potentiel pas des effets
avérés parce qu'on n'a jamais éliminé
les fonds à l'échelle industrielle
encore je le répète c'était toujours que
des tests et en plus on connaît pas très
bien les techniques qui seront utilisées
et on connaît si mal le fonctionnement
de ces écosystèmes que c'est difficile
d'évaluer les impacts de cette activité
en tout cas les impacts potentiels qu'on
a mentionnés ont été identifiés par des
scientifiques qui sont tous relativement
unanimes mais il y a pas uniquement les
effets que j'ai mentionné précédemment
qui sont à craindre certes on a parlé de
la destruction des habitats certains
ayant mis des millions d'années à se
former dépannage turbides de sédiments
avec une potentielle contamination
métallique des pollutions sonores et
lumineuses des engins qui travailleront
potentiellement jour et nuit en
affectant toutes les bestioles marines
et pas que celle du fond y compris les
mouettes mais c'est pas fini le meilleur
pour la fin si on remue tout le sédiment
comme ça là ça peut aussi relarguer
joyeusement le CO2 séquestrer dans les
sols océaniques depuis des millions
d'années ces piles le bon moment on en
manquait du CO2 ça pourrait aussi
empêcher l'océan en particulier les
plats abyssales et les sources
hydrothermales d'accomplir son rôle
depuis de carbone en perturbant les
communautés de microbes qui fixent ce
carbone normalement en décomposant les
joyeux cadavres qui tombent au fond de
l'eau
[Musique]
alors peut-on faire du Dipsy mining
durable mais vu les temps de formation
de ses ressources ça risque pas et même
si on a potentiellement des bons grosses
stocks qui nous permettraient de voir
venir pendant un moment elles ne sont
pas renouvelables à l'échelle humaine en
tout cas mais les métaux combines sur
terre non plus c'est pas le but et côté
impact sur les écosystèmes marins de
toute façon ce serait impossible d'avoir
0 impact et on part de loin quand même
avec le minage terrestre donc est-ce que
ça peut pas quand même représenter un
peu du mieux concernant l'impact
socio-environnemental toutes les études
ne sont pas d'accord entre elles
certaines affirment que le minage des
habits c'est sans doute moins coûteux ne
serait-ce que parce que tout se passe
sur l'eau donc pas besoin de construire
des infras des infrastructures le retour
du beatbox pas besoin de construire des
infrastructures ni des routes en
déforestant et expropriant gaiement et
qu'en plus les bateaux pourraient être
réutilisés après d'autres chercheurs
avancent que pas du tout et qu'une mine
en mer consommera plus d'énergie et
générera plus d'émissions que son
équivalent à terre bref difficile de
conclure d'autant plus qu'on connaît
trop peu les grands fonds pour estimer
vraiment les impacts d'une activité qui
n'a pas encore eu lieu et s'il y a un
accident sur terre ça peut être
catastrophique vous rappelez peut-être
de ce barrage brésilien car rompu en
2016 et répandu 50 millions de mètres
cubes de bout et de déchets toxiques a
tué 19 la personne est interrompu
l'accès à l'eau potable de centaines de
milliers d'habitants mais on voit quand
même quand il y a un accident ça peut
aussi prendre une ampleur inattendue
bref je suis assez d'accord assez Baker
voilà je suis assez délire bref je suis
assez d'accord avec ces chercheurs qui
écrivent en 2018 les coûts économiques
élevés de l'impact écologique du minage
terrestre sont souvent utilisés comme
argument en faveur du Dipsy mining
pourtant cette approche de pas à côté de
chez moi qu'il est pousse vers les fonds
marins violerait le principe de
précaution pour lequel les États se sont
accordés pendant le Sommet de Rio en
1992 le truc c'est qu'en plus on peut
craindre un effet pervers c'est pas
parce qu'on va miner dans les océans
qu'on va pour autant arrêter de miner
sur terre et toujours dans les mêmes
conditions donc au final ça pourrait
juste augmenter les stocks de métaux
disponibles c'est à dire augmenter
beaucoup plus vite l'offre que la
demande et en conséquence très
probablement faire s'effondrer le cours
des métaux sans qu'il y ait pour autant
de progrès sur le plan social ni
environnemental
bon maintenant que vous savez pourquoi
on s'intéresse au grand fonds et
pourquoi c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure idée d'aller extraire leur
richesse il reste une grande question
pourquoi on en parle maintenant et pour
y répondre j'invoque Raphaël alias
underwater baguette sur Instagram qui
est biologiste marin et militant contre
le Dipsy mining et il va nous raconter
des bonnes nouvelles donc c'est assez
rare en environnement faut en profiter
la semaine dernière la cop27 Macron a
affirmé que la France soutenait
l'interdiction de tout exploitation
minière des fonds marins cette position
va donc encore plus loin qu'un moratoire
qui est une pose temporaire et pour une
fois c'est pas que de la poudre de
perlimpinpin les paroles ont été suivies
d'actes quelques jours plus tard au
négociations de l'autorité
internationale des fonds marins
l'autorité chargée de réguler d'encadrer
l'industrie minière en haute mer au
passage soupçonné de conflits d'intérêt
avec les entreprises minières la France
a concrétisé sa position auprès des
autres États membres c'est une position
diplomatique forte qui positionne notre
pays aux côtés d'État comme le Costa
Rica le Chili le Panama la
Nouvelle-Zélande l'Allemagne ou
l'Espagne qui appelle un moratoire ou à
une pause de précaution sur cette
industrie étant donné le manque de
connaissances scientifique sur les
écosystèmes abyssaux et l'absence de
réglementation suffisante pour protéger
environnement mais le combat est loin
d'être fini il faut à présent ramener
d'autres pays dans le sillage de la
France pour bloquer le début de
l'exploitation des fonds marins en effet
la lutte contre le Dipsy mining est une
course contre-la-montre depuis qu'une
entreprise minière canadienne 2metals
compagnie a déclenché une loi dite la
loi des deux ans cette loi oblige
l'autorité internationale des fonds
marins délivrer les premiers contrats
d'exploitation minière deux ans après
son activation soit juin 2023 et ce peu
importe si un cadre réglementaire existe
ou non et puisque les scientifiques nous
disent qu'il nous faudra des décennies
pour comprendre les impacts
environnementaux du Dipsy minding il
sera impossible d'avoir un cadre
réglementaire strict d'ici là et c'est
pas des blagues les premiers tests alors
j’échelle ont déjà eu lieu en septembre
dernier de météos compagnie a obtenu une
autorisation pour récolter 3600 tonnes
de moutons de polymétalliques les
annonces récentes de la France
pourraient donner de l'élan au mouvement
antidique qui grandit de jour en jour
merci Raphaël si vous aimez la biologie
marine et les dessins précipitez vous
sur son compte Instagram underwater
baguette Raphaël qui est aussi membre du
collectif look down qui lutte contre
cette industrie au côté d'ONG comme la
SOA et d'activistes comme Camille
Étienne donc pour vous tenir au courant
des actualités autour du diply vous
savez où elle est moralité on va avoir
de plus en plus besoin de métaux dans
les années à venir est-ce que c'est une
bonne idée d'aller les chercher au fond
de l'océan et ben c'est pas si sûr miner
les écosystèmes abyssaux s'avérait
extrêmement invasif et destructeur qui
s'agisse des plats abyssales et leurs
nodules polymétiques des sourcils de
rothermales et leurs dépôts soufrés ou
encore des monts sous-marins et leurs
croûtes polymétaliques mais conséquence
inattendue le Dipsy mining pourrait
aussi avoir un impact sur la régulation
du climat par l'océan quand on pense que
certains de ces minerais servira à
développer l'économie verte ce cocasse
une autre idée plutôt que de chercher à
toujours extraire plus de ressources ce
serait de mettre l'accent sur
l'assobriété énergétique d'une part et
de développer d'autre part l'économie
circulaire pour recycler au max les
ressources qu'on a déjà extraites certes
on aura toujours besoin de métaux mais
il y a peut-être moyen qu'on en recycle
un paquet pour limiter notre impact sur
l'environnement en tout cas s'il y a un
truc que les études que les élus Martel
c'est qu'il faut plus de recherches
avant de faire quoi que ce soit à ce
jour moins d'un millième des habits ça a
été exploré donc avant de s'approprier
des ressources millénaires voir
millionnaire qui ont en plus une
signification culturelle ou spirituelle
pour certaines populations humaines
essayons d'explorer ces endroits
d'apprendre à les connaître comprendre
comment il fonctionne et protéger tout
de suite les zones les plus fragiles
avant de risquer de leur faire du mal ce
serait ballot de faire disparaître des
espèces avant même qu'on ait pu les
découvrir non
c'est l'heure de la page réclame merci à
cambli de soutenir cette chaîne imaginez
vous êtes sur scène en train de
dispenser votre éminence à voir à une
poignée de rezélu avec toujours la très
grande modestie qui vous caractérise
quand soudain dans le public quelqu'un
prend la parole et vous demande de
traduire en anglais ce que vous venez de
dire là tout le monde vous regarde et
attend imaginez un peu heureusement ça
n'arrive que dans les rêves ces choses
là
mais j'étais contente de ne pas avoir
perdu mes moyens déjà une pensée pour
tous les traducteurs qui font ça toute
la journée et qui eux le font bien bref
je pensais pas que ça allait m'arriver
un jour et pourtant heureusement que
j'étais un petit peu préparé peut-être
que vous aussi vous vous dites enfin ces
choses là n'arrive jamais auquel cas je
vous présente CAMBI cambli c'est un site
qui vous met en relation avec des
anglophones natifs et qui vous permet de
converser en anglais avec eux les tutos
viennent de plein d'endroits différents
ça permet de se faire un peu l'oreille
donc c'est cool et on peut même les
choisir selon leur accent il y a
toujours des tuteurs disponibles à toute
heure du jour ou de la nuit 7 jours par
semaine donc si à un moment vous avez
une envie soudaine de parler anglais à
3h du mat c'est possible vous vous
connectez sur le site vous choisissez
votre victime enfin votre tuteur et vous
ma poule vous pouvez avoir des
thématiques précises par exemple pour se
préparer au toïque un entretien
d'embauche un examen une présentation
orale ou simplement pour tailler le bout
de gras et par faire votre anglais
courant par exemple avant un séjour à
l'étranger parce que l'anglais écrit là
c'est bien mignon mais il y a que quand
on commence pouvoir tenir une
conversation avec quelqu'un que ça
devient un peu sérieux et non seulement
c'est bien mais grâce à moi c'est encore
mieux si vous cliquez sur le lien en
description de la vidéo vous disposez de
15 minutes de cours gratuit sans
engagement pour essayer cambire en
discutant avec le tuteur de votre choix
mais en plus bénéficier de 60% de
réduction sur votre abonnement de 12
mois j'ai bien dit soit 60% économiser
plus de la moitié du prix de
l'abonnement le lien est en description
n'hésitez pas à vous balader sur le site
pour voir à quoi ça ressemble et merci à
cambli de soutenir cette chaîne et de
vous permettre de devenir habitable
imbattable en anglais
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo merci à
underwater baguette pour sa
participation son gros coup de main sur
la biblio quel homme on se voit très
vite pour un sujet un peu plus joyeux
normalement et d'ici là
j'aurais trouvé une phrase de fin
[Musique]